[Music]
hi luke how are you
good how are y'all great how can ken
coleman and i help
so i'm currently in a job i'm 22 years
old and i've
been in this job for about two months um
and i've quickly found out that i'm not
really passionate about it why
um
well i'm i'm in the wine and liquor
industry i'm a sales rep
and it's just um
it's pretty difficult to watch people
come in in a store
um who already have a pretty difficult
life and walk out with your products um
it's just a hard thing to deal with
um hard to see that happening so it's a
values disconnect
yes for sure
everyone that walks into a liquor store
and buys wine is not having a bad life
yeah i i know that but it's uh it's the
ones that are i'm in a pretty um
pretty poor area
and so it's uh it's the ones that are
coming off the streets like just just
pennies in their pockets coming in and
finding the cheapest things on the shelf
just to get a just to get a drink why'd
you get into this you work in a liquor
store or you're a salesman for a
distributor
i'm a salesman for a distributor
so how are you dealing with the people
coming off the streets
well so i've got to go into the stores
and um
and and talk to the people to try and
talk to the the liquor store owners to
try and get them to get my products
um which a lot of them you know we have
some high-end products but a lot of them
are
to target those those
cheaper customers that are just trying
to get a quick drink
okay
i'm just curious and i understand all
the understanding it's very personal for
you what i'm curious about is how how
did you make this decision to get into
this
two months ago well
well i i uh
i wanted to originally get into medical
device sales
which is a very it's a difficult field
to get into without sales experience
and so my my original intention was to
just try and get my foot in the door for
the first couple years
um and just get some sales experience
under my belt so that i could then move
into that other um that other field but
it's just
right now it's it's getting pretty
difficult to you know i get going
because it's just it's just a moral
thing sure i get it but you took this
opportunity just because it was i need
some experience i got to sell something
and this presented itself and you jumped
into it that's what i'm understanding
exactly all right so here's the deal
stop overthinking this you're going to
stay in this role and you're going to
have to suck it up a little bit and
you're not doing anything morally wrong
i understand your feelings i don't want
in any way to discount what you're
feeling convictions all that but the
fact is you're not doing anything wrong
and so sit still and keep doing the job
until you find another sales job to
replace it with that's the advice and i
appreciate what you're trying to do get
some sales experience somewhere else but
now you've got to learn from this and go
wait it's like i'm not just going to
take any sales job i need to make sure
that i'm going to sell a service or
product
that i'm okay with and you can't
overthink this you know because again
there's nothing wrong with with
distributing alcohol or selling alcohol
but in your situation this is very very
personal so i wouldn't overthink this
let's make the move how about you how
much are you making
uh 45 000. okay so find another sales
job making forty five to sixty thousand
dollars selling something you're proud
of and then change that's what can say
that's right but then get in proximity
if you can if you could get selling
something that's near or around that
medical field i would try to look for
that first
you understand what i'm saying because
it's connections at this point not just
experience but connections
okay
and and make sure that as you're doing
that that you're taking on something you
can be proud of
everyone in sales needs to remember it's
very difficult to be a great sales
person selling something you don't
believe in yes
yeah and that's that's the thing that
i've been i've been struggling with
because yeah i've got alcoholism on both
sides of my family um from both my
parents sides
um
so it's that that's been the hardest
part is just not really
um
caring i don't really believe in the
products that i'm yeah that i'm selling
and that's been the the hardest part so
if if an opportunity similar to this
presents itself
don't take it
for sure there's something else because
you had red flags before you took this
yeah you're only two months in so i know
you did
and and now it's manifested and it's
actually worse than you thought it was
going to be
in terms of convicting you yeah and you
know your your morals are saying ding
ding ding ding ding the alarms are going
off get out of here so yeah go find
something else as soon as you can and
then quit but don't just quit every time
you have a
uh adversity
uh a situation you know so again i don't
want you there six years from now i
don't want you there six months from now
you ought to be able to find a sales job
doing that
so uh doing something that you actually
believe in
you know ken here over the years we've
developed we develop products books or
software or apps or
classes or whatever
and one of the biggest challenges is to
make sure that um
that we're all proud of
what it is we're putting out the instant
we're not proud of it
we can't ask anybody including me
to
suggest it to someone sell to someone
that's what sales is it's suggesting you
do something right
and uh you can't suggest
you know buying a car
if you hate
uh that brand and you think that brand's
a piece of crap
and then you're gonna go to work for
that dealer you know
uh and so yeah that's that's gonna be a
problem yeah so don't uh don't take a
position where you're not proud of
where you work
so true and specifically in sales
because sales you know period people
but it's very difficult very difficult
in sales because you're an evangelist
right that's your role and people can
fake it and there's a lot of fakes out
there that hit their sales numbers but
if you are a person of conviction and
you've got a true ethical code to you it
will wear you down if you can't get
excited to the point of evangelizing
on behalf of the product or the service
that you're selling it's absolutely it
will [ __ ] you it just will yeah it's
very difficult because people can
your
body language changes your tone that's
right changes your facial expressions
change all your non-verbals are are just
not there that's correct you know when
you're doing that and so
um
i mean if you're selling a uh in his
case a
a line of whiskey that is uh
you know
the bottom of the barrel no pun intended
um and um
and it's designed to take advantage of
the homeless then you're not gonna
you're gonna be fired up about that yeah
you know the drunk homeless guy right so
you're not gonna be jump you're not
nobody's gonna be excited about that
um now you know but uh so you just gotta
find
a way to do the thing you do
that is not violation of your morals or
find something period that isn't but
don't be just
after two months jumping out without
having something to jump to that well
that's right that's why the first thing
i said was hey you're gonna stay put and
you made this decision so you're gonna
be an adult about this until we find
something to replace that income you
don't just say i don't like it i can't
do it anymore and he wasn't saying that
but got to be careful
you know well i mean there's a that's
honorable work you know for a lot of
people yeah for him it's not a good fit
exactly